there can be no doubt that comic book
movies have taken the world by storm
assuring in a second Renaissance in the
geek culture community these films have
cultivated a new generation of readers
driven by the desire to learn about
heroes and villains who may have only
discovered for the very first time while
films like Man of Steel Captain America
and the Dark Knight have been a major
driving force in this comic book
resurgence their success like almost all
forms of innovation did not originate
with want but instead with necessity
winding back to 1970 and the years
following the introductions of Superman
in 1938 and Batman in 1939 the process
of buying and selling comic books was
regional a young man in possession of DC
showcase number four was forced to rely
on the honesty and integrity of his
local comic book shop to fetch a fair
price for the flash Barry Allen's first
appearance however in 1970
Robert M Overstreet who had long since
been a fan of comics launched the
Overstreet price guide which analyzed
the value of comic books taking into
account their condition and demand on
the national level armed with this
information coming book owners had a
recourse to shop owners who attempted to
lowball the value of these comics and
while the Overstreet price guide did
even a playing field it also set in
motion than your complete and total
collapse of the comic book industry
while some look to trade their comics in
the games give and take others look to
the value that where comics would have
in the future Bravin the bold number 28
amazing fantasy number 15 and all
American comics number 16 are just some
of the publications whose value was
noticed by investors around the country
looking to purchase these and new comics
of significance with the expectation
that their value would increase over
time the comic book collection community
expanded at an exponential rate as
everyone looked cash in
however because coming book distributors
simply recorded the number of comics
Coll regarding single issues the fact
that individuals were purchasing more
than one of the same comic was not taken
into account by companies like Marvel
and DC as a result the increased
purchase of comics led to an artificial
inflation of the market as publishers
simply saw a high rate of purchase
following this craft to his most logical
conclusion coming book publishers began
to flood the market with titles
sometimes with as many as 14 individual
variant covers and with the laws of
supply and demand being invoked these
comics once thought to be worth a
fortune
suddenly became almost worthless
that's forwarding to the mid-1990s
stories like the desert Superman
spider-man Clone Saga and Batman
nightfall spelled doom for publishers as
collectors began to drop off what was
originally a thriving market of comic
book stores entitled was now a labouring
beast gasping for breath having spent
the last decade attempting to license
out their titles to movie studios in the
hopes of expanding his brand the now two
front metal productions stood as a relic
of the past whose only success came in a
handful of live-action TV shows an
animated series forced to declare
bankruptcy in 1996 while immersed in a
mountain of debt under the direction of
avi arad
and after observing the landscape of
comic-book related movies and noticing
that Superman's run was effectively over
with Batman being the only recent
successful film based on a comic Marvel
auctioned off the film rights to the
x-men Fantastic Four spider-man and
others in a bid to stay afloat while
this financial shake-up was taking place
at Marvel chantix incorporated a
canadian-based family-owned toy company
had merged with random marketing
incorporated rebranding itself as Chiron
industries and becoming the leading
Canadian toy and marketing company of
the time selling off its toy subsidiary
to Isaac Perlmutter in 1990 Chiron toy
was rebranded his toy biz and allied
itself with Marvel Comics to begin the
production of mobile based toys in place
of Mattel
serving is something akin to a financial
backer in the time leading up to
Marvel's 1996 bankruptcy filing under
the oversight of toy biz CEO avi arad
Marvel was restructured from the ground
up leading to the formation of Marvel
Studios instead of producing their own
films at the outset Marvel Studios would
operate as a packaging house providing
screenplays directors and casting for
actors and lead roles with the intention
of licensing their lights and packages
to various production studios as a means
to regain financial solvency we're
marble and toy biz look to the future in
the wake of its bankruptcy filing Marvel
was forced to scrap their projects with
avi arad serving as the go-between for
the selling of marvel's film rights the
first deal came with blade which had
been sold to New Line Cinema
tomorrow surprise blade was a financial
success bringing in over 130 million
dollars worldwide but because of the
wording in the licensing deal marvel's
cut of the profits was only twenty five
thousand dollars seeing the success of
blade 20th Century Fox who had purchased
the film rights to the x-men in
Fantastic Four said about making their
own film hiring Bryan Singer to direct
and assembling an all-star cast x-men
was a massive success setting the record
for a comic book based film with an
opening weekend of more than 54 million
dollars originally grossing over 293
million dollars worldwide with Sony's
spider-man achieving even greater
success in 2002 with a 100 million
dollar opening weekend despite these
accolades and financial achievements
because the terms of the film rights
between Marvel's Fox and Sony had been
negotiated using a flat fee Marvel's
take from the financial success of these
films was absolutely nothing
during this time and in 2003 avi arad
had introduced Isaac Perlmutter to david
myself - at the time operated as the
corporate strategist and business
development head for endeavor talent
agency look into the idea that Marvel
could produce their own films thus
giving them total creative control and a
possible financial windfall if the films
were successful micelle arrange for
proof-of-concept
by initiating a series of animated
feature films produced through Marvel's
animation studio and distributed by
Lionsgate while not the most successful
of product the efforts of my cell Coffee
attempted a Perlmutter who tasked my
cell to come up with a plan that would
allow Marvel to launch their own
production studio acquiring capital
through the wealth management firm
Merrill Lynch with Marvel being 10 years
out from their bankruptcy filing the
price of support for Merrill Lynch was
high requiring collateral in exchange
for a five hundred and twenty five
million dollar loan Marvel was forced to
put out ten of their properties with the
stipulation being that if the loan went
into default Marvel would lose the
rights to Captain America the Avengers
Nick Fury Black Panther ant-man
cloak-and-dagger Doctor Strange Hawkeye
power pack and shang-chi recognizing the
terms of their loan along with the
uncertain length and popularity of
superhero movies net do or die Marvel
was effectively going for broke this
combined with the departure of Avi Arad
in 2006 owing to his dislike of taking
on debt so soon after bankruptcy as well
as the inability to use the most popular
characters and teams in film forum left
Marvel in a state of panic as the
company searched frantically for a
viable property or some will say that
Marvel experienced a stroke of luck
while others might argue fate the fact
remains that the success of Marvel
Studios would come down to one man who
would personify the adage that fortune
favors the bold
a graduate from the University of
Southern California School of Art Kevin
Feige
was the grandson of Robert a short an
executive for Procter & Gamble's company
own soap opera as the world turns
credited with being an assistant to film
producer Laura Shuler Donner on projects
including volcano and you've got mailed
with Fox intending to launch their film
in 2000 and Donner acting as a producer
5yz research into the Marvel Universe
revealed a rich tapestry of interwoven
stories involving the x-men and Avengers
as well as a multitude of other heroes
and villains in the 2014 article by
Devin Leonard of Bloomberg titled how
Kevin Feige became one of the most
powerful producers in Hollywood
Feige admitted to immersing himself in
Marvel in an attempt to better assist
Donner through her actions as producer
seeing the x-men as a grounded team
whose core Charter reflected societal
struggles against oppression Bundy's
creative input as seen in the x-men
films narratives of good versus evil and
Xavier pursuit of a peaceful coexistence
between humans and Metis catching the
attention of Avi Arad prior to his
departure and with Isaac Crowe mother's
toy BIG's backing the now rebranded
Marvel Entertainment Feige was hired by
Arad and worked as the head of creative
input regarding the production of
further movies based on Marvel titles
expanding his input two x-men 2 as well
as Sony spider-man Feige established
himself as the foremost authority on
Marvel's comic book related material in
the eyes of Hollywood's film producers
however and foggy zone eyes for
spider-man x-men and x-men 2 proved to
be cash cows these studios were missing
a key component necessary to ensure the
success of the franchise for the
long-term and the mind of foggy helming
books film cost success through the
suspension of disbelief and the draw of
imagination however as these films
lingered on and their number grew it was
inevitable the viewership would
fluctuate as moviegoers began to step
into new aspects of their lives and left
the film's behind to that end foggy
believed that if comic book films were
going to last any real measure of time
these production studios had to tap into
in game in support of the hardcore
fanbase and an effort to ensure that
their films were received in a positive
light and maintain healthy profit
margins
you
rapping back around a 2006 following avi
arad departure and Marvel's intention to
initiate their own line of film fate
seemed to smile on Feige as his rise
when standing within Marvel Studios
coincided with the return of the film
rights for Iron Man Thor and Black Widow
with Iron Man experiencing unprecedented
popularity among comic readers following
the critically acclaimed story Civil War
two Feige in the creative circle of Joe
Quesada Brian Michael Bendis and others
if Marvel Studios were to launch a
feature film Iron Man was the best
choice considering their lineup truth to
tell Marvel Studios took more than a
little risk with their approach to Iron
Man John Favreau
whose acting and director work was
largely composed of comedies was
appointed to the position of director
how they worked with avi arad on 2003
daredevil during Iron Man's planning
phase farboro pitched the idea to make
Tony Stark more complex as well as
updating his origin story to see his
capture taking place in Afghanistan
instead of Vietnam turning their
attention to cast in the leading role
both Marvel and father understood the
weight of their choice if the leading
actor for Iron Man failed to resonate
with fans the film would tink along with
Marvel's hopes of a continued franchise
however if the film succeeded marvelled
would wave the flag of victory and usher
in a new type of comic book superhero
genre faced with these facts while
Marvel initiated a series of casting
calls for potential actors - Jon Favreau
there was only ever one actor capable of
becoming 20 stark speaking to the Dallas
radio station 100.3 Jack fm in 2014
Farber have stated that in his mind
where Tony Stark being a character whose
past was mired in alcoholism and the
pressures of superhero life the actor
for the leading role needed to come from
a place that allowed them to draw on
similar experiences having recently
emerged from his own experiences and
attempting to find work in Hollywood
Robert Downey jr. stood as father as
first and only choice rejected at every
turn by Marvel who believed the Robert
Downey jr. was too large of a risk
Bob ro looked down his work colouring
his return to Hollywood which included
Gothica as well as a number of semi
independent films like a guide to
recognizing her sing good
and good luck as well as zodiac in the
2008 interview with a list a magazine
dedicated to arts and entertainment in
the United Kingdom farboro had stated
that during the casting process his
arguments of marble was the Downey's own
experiences mirrored there was a 20
start succeeding and making his case
Iron Man was released in May of 2008
opening at number one in the box office
critics and fans hailed Robert Downey
jr. performance considering him to be
the highlight of the film indeed for the
hardcore fans of Iron Man Robert Downey
jr. and Tony Stark seemed one in the
same as Downey was able to draw on his
own personal struggles with success and
failure achieving a gross of nearly 100
million dollars in may of 2008 by the
end of his theatrical run Ironman had
garnered over 500 million dollars in
revenue
moreover Marvel Studios stood on the
success of their film and under the
direction of Kevin Feige look to the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe